[Music]
Mr. Éric Fidol, good morning.
Good morning.
I'm interviewing you today for a
website called Syerview.
I would have liked to have your
expertise on the recent
Prisme leaks, on the leaks that different
companies and organizations
organize or allow to happen.  What do
you think?
Ah, it's a huge debate, actually.  Prism
first, what you need to know is that it's
not the... what is the name of
the first... the first
case.  In fact, Prisme is just a
specific sub-program of a
larger plan.
In the past, it was called, it is also part of a
program that we
know called the Gelon, uh,
one of whose subprograms was uh,
carnivore.  Yeah, you have to understand that
controlling technologies involves
controlling the actors who
implement those technologies.  So it's even
more powerful than that.  It's not that
the companies were incriminated, and
besides, some companies are missing,
and letting data leak or get
out.  It is
simply an obligation for
American companies to work
with the State and in particular with the
American intelligence services.   It's
another world, it's not very much in line with
the European vision, but
it's an obligation.  First, we forget
that there is this obligation, it comes
from the Patriot Act
which is a law which was certainly
created by Bush Junior, but whose
latest and most recent developments
were signed and validated by Obama.
Hence the embarrassment of the
current administration, which could not have been
unaware.
These are concerted plans, organized
for the control of technologies.
What are the repercussions for
the French citizen?  Ah well for the
French citizen, for the
European citizen, I would say well it's simple, it's that
I would say that while they may be
worrying for the average citizen,
they are more worrying for
French companies.  Whenever you use a
service like Facebook, when you
use Google as a search engine
, when you use a
well-known operating system, when you use
an iPhone.  In any case, the data
that we put in it, and again,
it's not just personal data,
there's also company data.
This data should be considered as if it were an
open book.
You mentioned Facebook, what have
you discovered about Facebook?
What are the repercussions of
Facebook on people's privacy?   In more
detail.
So, firstly, from a general point of view, you
should know that Facebook, I think it's a
superb success.  We succeeded in creating
the world's largest private intelligence agency
.
That's truly amazing.  And where
people voluntarily share their own data
.  So that's already
great.  But it's true, we've discovered
a number of things, we haven't
discovered everything, it's that uh, partly
in the field of mobile telephony,
when you connect to Facebook,
the Facebook application
retrieves, without the user's knowledge,
loads of data which they hide
on the phone.  So, she doesn't hide them that much
because they are not
encrypted, but they are stored.
Basically, the Facebook app on
Android behaves like a real
sponge.  We know from other hackers
that when Facebook claims to
confirm that it has deleted your
data, in reality that data is
still present.  There is a
simple little experiment to do.  To delete
your Facebook profile or
account, simply go to
a login banner, enter your
old credentials, and like
magic, your page reappears.  That means
everything is stored.  Everything is
stored.  We don't store things without a
purpose.  In reality, Facebook should be seen
as the most gigantic,
uh, I mean intelligence organization
that has ever been made.
It's stasis to the power of whatever you
want.
Who in France, what organization in
France, can protect people?  Who can
protect businesses?  What
measures has the
French State taken to protect us as businesses
and as citizens?  So,
normally, we have uh the ACNI, the
National Commission for Information Technology and
Freedom.  The problem is that
its powers are limited and are
increasingly eroded, notably by the
provisions of the World
Trade Organization, by extremely
intensive and multinational lobbying which makes it
increasingly difficult for
the CLI and similar bodies
in Europe to bring these large
companies to heel.  We have seen all the
difficulty that there has been in
forcing Google to modify,
in particular, the so-called
privacy protection rules.  The
Germans were less inefficient than
the French.  It's a problem of resources
but also of political will.  Uh,
so after, uh, the protection, well, that's
not a technical problem.  First of all, we are
free to choose whether
or not to use Facebook.  So I think there's
an education problem.  There is a
problem in making users
aware of the
risks.
But I think there is also a role
for politicians to prohibit certain
practices and to require certain
security measures.  So
actually the more general problem is that
when you are in a company the
problem is not so much the
technology, it is the law on which it
depends.  There is a
fundamental difference in European and
French law, whereby the data
entrusted to a service provider
continues to be your property.  This
means that the service provider has an
obligation, or at least a minimum means, to
protect your data.  Whereas in general
Anglo-Saxon culture, data belongs to
those who process it.  So, a
journalist whose name I've forgotten
had a subtle formula.  At Google,
you are the product.
So once you submit your
data, it belongs to him, he is
free to do what he wants with it, to
give it to whomever he wants, to exploit it
commercially.  And that's a
fundamental difference.  So, one would say that
the first rule for a company
is to look
among the different service providers that are
available to it, and to look at
what right this provider or
company depends on.  So, it's difficult
because when you're a
multinational, a large
French company, well, you have to look at whether, for
example, the capital doesn't include
American pension funds, whether the company is
subject to French law, it
becomes increasingly complex.  And that's why
I would advise
SMEs and SMIs to favour
a different offering; we talk a lot about
cloud or
outsourced hosting, but rather to choose
smaller regional players who will
offer a guarantee regarding the
security measures taken on the
data entrusted to them.
You talked about politicians, about
legislators.
Um, what can you tell us
about their training?  Are they ready?
Are they sufficiently trained to
properly understand the risks
involved in digital technology?  Do you
think that these same legislators
are too beholden to
pressure groups?  Are these legislators
entirely honest?  Are
the legislators
acting in the general interest?
In fact, there are several aspects to this question
.  First, it should be noted that
in France at least, the training
of politicians is ill-suited to
the evolution of the technological world.  We
have people who have often done what we
call their humanity.  This is
a more legal training, possibly history of
law for those less
literary or economic, but we
find ourselves in a situation where we have decision-
makers who no longer understand anything about
technology and who
unfortunately make decisions that impact
our lives.  It's important to know that computer science,
information technology, and
the security that goes with it now
affect our lives when we go to
the hospital or when we file our taxes.   In
short, in every little thing you do and gesture,
and that's important to know.
So we have politicians
who no longer understand technology,
if they ever did
.  So it's not a problem in
absolute terms because we can't be
specialists in everything.  This means that,
as is the case in some countries,
I am thinking in particular of Germany
which has indeed been able to capitalize on
its community of winners, it
means that you need to be well surrounded, you
need to have advisors who
have a sense of the state and
I think that since General de
Gaulle, this sense has been largely lost.  We
have lobbyists.  So, I'm sorry,
the lobbyist, lobbying is a
term, let's say politically
correct.  In Africa, this is often called
corruption.  Well,
when we see how some
public contracts, especially recently, have been
violated,
well, it's a
semantic problem, we can say, but
it still resembles what we
criticize in others.  The problem,
in fact, I believe, is that we need to
return to a certain idea of ​​the State, to
a certain integrity and independence,
a certain strength of character so that
our politicians are surrounded
by good advisors.  So, this touches on
another aspect, which is the selection of
our elites.  The problem is that we
cannot represent the entire
nation with only a small
fraction coming from just a few
schools.  The thing about France being behind,
compared for example to Germany which has
been very pragmatic in this respect
, is that France is cutting itself off
from a
significant fraction of the population of
extremely high quality that we
usually call hackers.  So in
France, the problem is that the word
hacker is demonized.  We
simply forget that these are people who
prioritize results over
methods and who are capable of gaining
an intimate knowledge of a system.  These
are not at all the
malicious actors we want to be
described.  They often use
the word pirate, in fact.  This means that
these people are demonized and
completely excluded from the debate, even though they
could contribute.  There is
much talk about citizen reserves, but if it is
only to be done with graduates of
Polytechnique, Normales, and
Centrale, we are not going to get very far.
I think we need all the goodwill we can
get.  We need to
look more at what a young person can
contribute to the state, rather than what they did
between the ages of 20 and 24.  And then, I am
sure that France will once again
become a leading nation
.  We must remember that there is
a French genius, and not just from
our elite schools.  I usually
tell my students that we
are a subtle and also somewhat
aberrant mix of difference and Gallic spirit.
Well, we see it in the
French hacker community.  We are fortunate in
France to have a very vibrant,
very innovative community.  Unfortunately, a
large proportion of them go to the
United States.  It should also be noted that
many hackers, whether Junior
Security Hacker or Senior Security
Hacker at Google, Microsoft, Apple,
Oracle, Novell, are French and that's a
shame.
You're talking about Microsoft.  Um, what
can you tell us about the
contracts that have been signed by the
defense?  Let's say that he doesn't
really respect the rules regarding
public procurement and that
transparency has not prevailed.
But I mean, now all the
documents have been published and they
prove that indeed there may
be some housecleaning and some
practices, uh, I mean, to uh, to
review.  Now you need to know that
France has made the choice to return
to NATO in a very, very important and total way.  NATO imposes its rules, and
when I say it imposes its rules, I mean it
imposes mostly American products.
So it's very delicate for our
politicians and unfortunately we haven't had a
General de Gaulle for a
very long time.  Uh, it's very delicate
to backtrack, or at least
to reaffirm a certain sovereignty,
but in any case, we won't have
security if we don't go through this.
You are referring to certain practices during
the awarding of certain contracts with the
defense.  Can you
elaborate?
Let's say that lobbying and
specific rules
apply, whereas the public market and
public market rules should
apply.  We saw all the documents,
we saw that indeed there was no
transparency.  Particularly in France,
there is an obligation when you enter into
a contract to always
give priority to the free software offer
when it is
available, when it is presented.  But first, it
needs to be generated.  However, in this case
, uh,
during the tendering process, we did
not ensure that there would be people from
the free software community who could
offer an alternative.
What became of the people who
signed these contracts with Microsoft?
So, let's broaden the debate a bit,
but in France, there is a rule that says
that every senior civil servant,
military or not, when they leave
the administration has an obligation not to
work for 5 years in
the company with which they
worked as a civil servant.
I will leave it to the people who
watch this video to do a little
research and look at where some
of our civil servants go, who they are
recruited by, and we will see that it is a rule
which is unfortunately regularly
flouted.
The duty of discretion is
more than just the duty of discretion.  The
duty of discretion applies when one
is in office.
So the 40-day period
is what constitutes a
waiting period.  what we could call a
period where we will say I don't know if it's
a non-competition clause or in fact
there is an obligation not to work
in a field or with a company
with which we have entered into contracts.   Alright
.  One last word, what
can you
tell us about your perception on
whistle blowers?  Julian Assange, Jeremy
Amand, Bradley Manings?  So, I think that,
well,
Aon Schwartz,
I think these people have a
positive role.  On the other hand, it bothers me
because, if you will, it is still
the sad spectacle that, first of all, you
have to know that the information
most often comes from internal sources.
So yes, we can always say
that they revealed things that he
was good, uh, when he was good, in
any case that were interesting and that brought
certain facts to light.
Now, they delivered it in a way that was
perhaps irresponsible in some cases
.  In any case, it testifies
to a malaise and a breakdown of
society.
You draw a parallel with Vladimir
Vetrof, the Farwell affair, this Russian who was
fed up with this corrupt hierarchy and who
leaked
French intelligence.
Except that I won't put the same thing,
I won't put it on the same level.
Pharaoh did it at the risk of his life
and he did it knowing that he would
remain anonymous.  He did it because
I think he was an idealist, as far as
I know.  Indeed,
I think he was someone who
was indeed disgusted
by certain practices or had understood
that the world was going to change.  It cannot be
denied that some of these
whistleblowers have a certain ego and it
is difficult to know what
their real motivations are.
I still find it worrying that
a company, because there
can be ware in
French companies.  I think it illustrates
more the fact that, well, the notions of
loyalty, the notions of fidelity, or
let's say it's a form of theft.  When you
take data that doesn't belong to you and
put it in the public domain
without any context, it still poses
problems.  But I think it reveals a certainty that we
are an increasingly
sick society where money reigns supreme,
power reigns supreme, and there you have it, it's
just a sign.  So then, well, that's what
revealed it, what revealed
Snowden, indeed it's
interesting.  Now, this will inevitably raise
issues of, let's say,
national and
international security.
I think that perhaps we should indeed
put in place a
number of
mechanisms so that,
well, whistleblowers can do it, but
that it is still, well, I won't
say control because the word
protects, legislatively speaking,
whistleblowers.
Yes.  Yes.  But it already exists for
the tax administration.
That's a megabyte problem.  We are
really favoring people who, in my
opinion, and I could be wrong, still
act a lot out of ego.
They often act
irresponsibly because we forget that
the Wikileak affair still dragged
the names of people who
were servants of their state into the public sphere.
So we may not agree with
the American state, but these are people
who had an ideal and who
serve their country and I think we do
n't have the right to do it in that way
.
Prisme was preceded by a program
called Stellar Wind.
What do you think of a
secret program that is capable of making a
complete map of a population, of a
company, on the
consumption habits, the
behavioral habits of a population?  Do
you think this is a
way that the state, forced by a
financial crisis, may have found to gauge the
mood of its population and be able to
control future or potential
rebel movements?  You're talking about
Google here.  That's what Google does.
I mean, there are tools like
Collusion that, as soon as you do the
slightest search, you
're already mapped and you receive tons of
stuff.  Then, it is true that there are
two interesting trends: we are
very concerned and we talk a
lot about big data, but that is, let's
say, the marketing term for something we haven't
known for a long time,
called data mining, which
actually looks for big trends.  What
is indeed clear and what
is interesting in the question is
that these techniques are
now less interested in major trends
than in what are called
weak signals, precursor signals and in what in
data mining is called
outler search.  Indeed, uh,
so I would be very surprised if
projects like this didn't exist
now.  Are they secret, are they, and
all that?  Finally, I mean, I would say
that ultimately any decision-maker
and politician, I would say that if he did not do it
, he would be unconscious and
incompetent.  Then, you have to see under
what conditions it is done, for what
purpose, and other things.  But it is true that these
techniques are very interesting and,
moreover, they determine the collection
of a huge amount of data.  As we have seen, there have been
many
strategic and geostrategic upheavals.  We can
talk about revolutions 2.0, but we can't just
look at what's happening in the
world.  Many were not necessarily
planned, perhaps because those plans
were not yet active.  We
realize, then it's always easy
in hindsight to say, well, if we had
done this and that, we would have seen it.  It is
clear that this will indeed become, if
it is not already the case, a
very important technological direction,
in any case a leading one,
which could prove dangerous.
Afterwards, if the
weak signal is the preparation of
terrorist attacks, everyone will be pleased
that we can
identify them and prevent them because every
citizen who has a family wants to
be protected.  If now it's about
anticipating
protest movements, you know, uh, a
resistance fighter is a terrorist who didn't
succeed, right?  Well, in some countries,
terrorist calls are called resistance;
it's just a problem of semantics and
reference points.  Well, that's the situation for now,
you know, uh, in Syria,
well, if you ask Bashar and Laassad,
they are dangerous terrorists.  The
perception is not the same at all.
Do you have any recommendations or
advice for the generations
listening to us, perhaps
future generations of hackers? What
advice can you leave them?
I believe it's about keeping an open mind
and a humble spirit, and above all,
trying not to fight against it and
not giving in to the technological siren call.  We
talk a lot about prisms, but we forget one
thing: we have the right, we have the
power not to use Facebook,
not to use Google.  There are
alternatives.  There is a very nice website
called
prism-break.org
which, for each software and technology
related to Prisme, quite
often provides an alternative in the
world of free software.  So, I
simply have to think that we need to
educate the population and young people
are part of it, they are among the people
who will educate later when they need to be
open to others.  We
must ensure that
knowledge is passed on.  Knowledge
cannot be a
marketable commodity, and one must
simply exercise one's rights as a citizen.
There will be, we will have either freedom or
security, but we will not have had
Mr. Filiol, what do you
think of the cultural exception?
How was this brought about?  Have we
forgotten certain things in the
French cultural exception?
I think we can have a
free culture when we already have, I would say,
security, and I find it normal that in
free trade agreements, we are
not included alongside the famous
cultural exception, we are not given
priority inclusion of
security products.
Well, what the United States is already doing is that it
is forbidden in the United States to equip itself with
non-domestic security products, which
also violates
the order and free
trade agreements.  I think it should be
mandatory to make security products
and security technologies
an essentially national thing and
therefore include them in the
exclusion lists of free trade agreements.
[Music]